Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，因为 Eglinton Crosstown 轻轨列车正在进行测试。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能在轨道上通过。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Whether in the game or in life, the right coverage can make all the difference. Securian Canada gives you that coverage. For more than 65 years, Securian Canada has been helping Canadians build secure tomorrows. Their insurance solutions are designed to help protect you and your loved ones financially, giving you the peace of mind to focus on what truly matters.
请保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。无论是在比赛中还是在生活中，合适的保障都能带来截然不同的结果。Securian Canada 为您提供这种保障。65 年多来，Securian Canada 一直在帮助加拿大人构建安全的未来。他们的保险解决方案旨在帮助您和您的家人在经济上获得保障，让您能够安心专注于真正重要的事情。
Find their products through banks, credit unions, and associations, or visit SecurianCanada.ca. Securian Canada, insurance designed for life. I see, I know. I began to see when I was not yet born, when I was not in my mother's arms, but inside of my mother's belly. It was there that I began to study about my people.
您可以通过银行、信用合作社和协会找到他们的产品，或访问 SecurianCanada.ca。Securian Canada，为生活而设计的保险。我看见了，我知道。我还在娘胎里，还没在母亲怀里时，我就开始看见了。就在那时，我开始了解我的人民。
God gave me the power to see out of the womb. I studied there, in the womb, about many things. I studied about the smallpox that was killing my people, the great sickness that was killing the women and children. I was so interested that I turned over on my side. The God Almighty must have told me at that time that I would be the man to be the judge of all the other Indians, a big man to decide for them. So that, Dominic, was the Lakota chieftain, Sitting Bull, talking to a Chicago Times reporter in 1877, which is the year after
上帝赐予我力量，让我能从子宫里向外看。我在那里，在子宫里，研究了许多事情。我研究了正在杀害我人民的天花，那种正在夺走妇女和儿童生命的巨大瘟疫。我太感兴趣了，以至于翻了个身。全能的上帝一定是在那时告诉我，我将成为裁决所有其他印第安人的那个人，一个为他们做决定的大人物。所以，多米尼克，那就是拉科塔酋长“坐牛”（Sitting Bull），他在 1877 年对《芝加哥时报》记者所说的话，那是在
The Little Bighorn, when he was probably one of the most famous people, not just in America, but maybe in the world. Yeah, that's right. And it's all, from our perspective, quite odd, isn't it? It's odd, Tom, yeah. Being given visions in the womb and things like that. Yes, absolutely it is. Captures the strangeness, I think, that has always surrounded the Sioux sitting bull.
小大角战役之后的一年，当时他可能不仅是美国，甚至可能是世界上最著名的人之一。是的，没错。从我们的角度来看，这一切都很奇怪，不是吗？是的，汤姆，这很奇怪。在子宫里获得异象之类的事情。是的，绝对是这样。我认为，这捕捉到了那种一直围绕着苏族“坐牛”的神秘感。
And I guess to people from Britain, there's always this sense of Tom, to use a Tom Hollandism. Is it not a case of the weird? I think it is. And that, I guess, is also completely part of the fascination and charisma of not just sitting bull, but of the Lakota and the Indians generally, who for Custer and people like him back in the late 19th century, were objects of fascination, but also seen as savages, as primitives. And obviously that is a perspective that has changed quite radically over the past decades. It has, absolutely. So when I was growing up in the 70s, cowboy and Indian films were still on TV a lot.
我想对于英国人来说，总会有这种感觉，汤姆，用一个“汤姆·霍兰主义”来说，这难道不是一种怪异吗？我想是的。而且，我想这也是不仅对“坐牛”，而且对拉科塔人和印第安人整体魅力的重要组成部分。对于 19 世纪末的卡斯特（Custer）和像他那样的人来说，他们既是令人着迷的对象，也被视为野蛮人、原始人。显然，这种观点在过去几十年里已经发生了根本性的改变。确实如此，绝对是。所以当我 70 年代长大时，电视上仍然有很多牛仔和印第安人的电影。
I had children's books. I can remember them. Ernest and the Wild West. There was the Lady Bird book. The Lady Bird book of Custer. Custer's Last Stand. Yeah. And those books freely used the term, which a lot of people now find very offensive,
我有儿童读物。我记得它们。《欧内斯特与狂野西部》。还有“瓢虫书”（Lady Bird book）。关于卡斯特的瓢虫书。《卡斯特的最后防线》。是的。那些书随意使用了现在许多人认为非常冒犯的词汇，
Red Indian, or indeed Redskins, like the Washington Redskins. But there was always a sense of, you call it the weird, that the divide between the world of the everyday mundanity and the supernatural was very thin with Native Americans. And that still hangs over them, right? There's sort of a sense of, oh, all the books about them are called things like the earth is weeping the earth is all that lasts well in the 90s there was sacred spirit sacred spirits yeah which was kind of ambient music put to native american chanting yes and it kind of conveyed an idea of timeless wisdom yes i suppose a sense that native americans were guardians of the earth all of that stuff is still very apparent.
“红印第安人”（Red Indian），或者确实是“红皮肤”（Redskins），就像华盛顿红皮队那样。但总有一种感觉，你称之为“怪异”，即日常生活与超自然世界之间的界限在美洲原住民身上非常薄弱。这种感觉至今仍笼罩着他们，对吧？有一种感觉，哦，所有关于他们的书都叫《大地在哭泣》、《大地是唯一永恒的》之类的名字。好吧，在 90 年代有《神圣精神》（Sacred Spirit），是的，那是一种配上美洲原住民吟唱的环境音乐，它传达了一种永恒智慧的理念。是的，我想这是一种认为美洲原住民是地球守护者的感觉，所有这些东西至今仍然非常明显。
So if you go, you know, last year I was traveling in the American Southwest and in the shops and stuff, you know, there's still a lot of buy this lovely blanket. Here's a CD of people chanting. Here's some sort of incense that you can burn that will make you commune with the spirits. Sort of new agey, I guess is the... Yeah. And the thing about being timeless. So as we were discussing
所以如果你去，你知道，去年我在美国西南部旅行，在商店里，你知道，仍然有很多“买这条漂亮的毯子吧。这是人们吟唱的 CD。这是你可以燃烧的某种香，它会让你与灵魂交流”。我想这是一种新时代（New Age）的感觉……是的。关于永恒的事情。所以正如我们正在讨论的
today's podcast which is all about the lakota about crazy horse and sitting bull their world is absolutely not timeless their world has changed enormously and it's always changing the whole time and nobody's in the right place everybody's customs have changed a lot in recent years they are as liable to the influence of technology and trade and all those things as anybody else. So it's a huge stereotype. So the classic image of the Plains Indians, as they would have been called in the 19th century, is they're hunting buffalo. They have horses.
今天的播客，全是关于拉科塔人、疯马（Crazy Horse）和“坐牛”的，他们的世界绝对不是永恒的，他们的世界发生了巨大的变化，而且一直在不断变化。没有人处于正确的位置，每个人的习俗近年来都发生了很大变化，他们和任何人一样，容易受到技术、贸易和所有这些事物的影响。所以这是一个巨大的刻板印象。因此，19 世纪所称的平原印第安人的经典形象是他们正在猎杀野牛。他们有马。
Yeah. They have guns. Yeah. You know, they're not just armed with bows and arrows. And obviously all of these are very recent. Totally. Exactly. By the way, we've already so far in the first few minutes gone all over the shop with our nomenclature, haven't By the way, we've already, so far in the first few minutes,
是的。他们有枪。是的。你知道，他们不仅仅是用弓箭武装。显然所有这些都是非常近期的。完全正确。顺便说一句，我们在前几分钟里已经在命名法上绕了一大圈了，不是吗？顺便说一句，我们在前几分钟里
gone all over the shop with our nomenclature, haven't we? Yeah, we have. Because we might call them the Lakota, the Sioux, we've used Native Americans, and we've used Indians. And obviously, the one thing that they're not is, as it were, Indians from India, which is a label put on them by European settlers. But the complicating thing is that some natives now have reclaimed the word Indian and are very keen on it, and some absolutely loathe it. So whatever we do, Tom, well, we're going to be offending somebody. Well, I think it also reflects the fact that no matter the, you know, Dee Brown, Bury My Heart at Wounded Knee, and all the attempts to see how the West was won as being how the West was lost, it remains the fact that it is a Western, white, American historiographical tradition that frames this story.
已经在命名法上绕了一大圈了，不是吗？是的，我们绕了一大圈。因为我们可能称他们为拉科塔人、苏族人，我们用了“美洲原住民”，也用了“印第安人”。显然，他们唯一不是的就是来自印度的印第安人，那是欧洲定居者给他们贴上的标签。但复杂的事情在于，一些原住民现在已经重新启用了“印第安人”这个词，并且非常喜欢它，而有些人则绝对厌恶它。所以无论我们怎么做，汤姆，我们都会冒犯到某人。嗯，我认为这也反映了一个事实，无论迪·布朗（Dee Brown）的《魂归伤膝河》（Bury My Heart at Wounded Knee），以及所有试图将“西部是如何被征服的”视为“西部是如何失去的”的尝试，事实仍然是，正是西方的、白人的、美国的史学传统构建了这个故事。
Totally is. And it's really, really difficult to get back into the mindset of a people whose traditions and way of life are utterly devastated over the course of the period that we are describing. So much so that you don't even appreciate often the entirety of what has been lost. And that sense of the strangeness of the weirdness, of course, it's only strange and weird to us. Yeah, absolutely. It's not to them.
完全是这样。要回到一个在我们要描述的时期内，其传统和生活方式被彻底摧毁的人民的心态中，真的非常非常困难。以至于你往往甚至无法理解所失去的一切。那种怪异感、那种诡异感，当然，这只是对我们来说才奇怪和诡异。是的，绝对是。对他们来说并非如此。
No, no, you're absolutely right. Even that quotation that we began with, by the way. Yeah, because he's giving it to a newspaperman. And so he's playing a part, he's playing a role, and he'll go on to play the role of the Indian chieftain in Buffalo Bill's Wild West story. Yes, exactly that. It's filtered through the newspaper man. And even, I mean, all the books that I've read, all those books that I was just talking about, you know, the earth is all that lasts, the earth lies weeping, all that kind of, the vast majority of them are by white American, you know, university academics who are often putting in the traditions of your
不，不，你是绝对正确的。顺便说一句，即使是我们开头引用的那段话。是的，因为他是对报社记者说的。所以他在扮演一个角色，他将继续在布法罗·比尔（Buffalo Bill）的“狂野西部”故事中扮演印第安酋长的角色。是的，正是如此。它是通过报社记者过滤出来的。甚至，我的意思是，我读过的所有书，我刚才谈到的那些书，你知道，《大地是唯一永恒的》、《大地在哭泣》，所有这些，绝大多数都是由白人美国大学学者写的，他们往往把你们
people, to get back to the mindset of someone like Sitting Bull, who lived in a world that was not yet entirely American. Because the scale of the devastation, the cultural devastation is so profound that everyone in America now is completely Americanized. Yeah, I think there's a degree of truth. And of course, we know how the story plays out, which Sitting Bull never knew. But I think part of the tragedy and the heroism of this story is that they kind of do know. The smartest of them do know. Right. Some of them certainly do know.
人民的传统放进去，试图回到像“坐牛”那样的人的心态，他生活在一个尚未完全美国化的世界里。因为破坏的规模，文化上的破坏是如此深远，以至于现在美国的每个人都完全被美国化了。是的，我认为这有一定程度的真实性。当然，我们知道故事的结局，这是“坐牛”从未知道的。但我认为这个故事的悲剧和英雄主义的一部分在于，他们某种程度上确实知道。他们中最聪明的人确实知道。没错。他们中的一些人肯定知道。
And as we'll see, Sitting Bull has a power to see into the future. Yeah. At least that is what people believe. I mean, his people believe it. He believes it. And the visions that he gets, although they do foretell the great victory over Custer that will happen at the Little Bighorn, you know, it's full of ominous forebodings as well. All right, Tom, well, we'll get onto that in due course, but maybe we should
正如我们将看到的，“坐牛”有一种预见未来的能力。是的。至少人们是这么认为的。我的意思是，他的人民相信这一点。他自己也相信。他得到的异象，虽然确实预示了在小大角战役中对卡斯特的伟大胜利，但它也充满了不祥的预兆。好吧，汤姆，我们会在适当的时候谈到这一点，但也许我们应该
crack on with the story. Let's start, shall we? Should we give some very, very broad context, so the camera will kind of zoom in as the first half of this podcast continues. So let's go back to the very beginning of this story, the very, very beginning. So 1492, Columbus arrives in the New World. In today's United States and Canada, how many native people are there? There are probably somewhere around the region of three, four million. Some historians would go as high as seven or eight million. But that number drops incredibly dramatically over the next few centuries, largely because of disease, not because of campaigns, battles or anything like that, but it's smallpox in particular. taxpaying american colonists expand they become independent and they expand westward disease obviously travels and the number of native peoples continues to collapse so by about the early 1800s there may be fewer than three quarters of a million and continuing to fall very quickly now
继续讲故事。我们开始吧，好吗？我们是否应该提供一些非常非常广泛的背景，这样随着本期播客前半部分的继续，镜头会拉近。所以让我们回到这个故事的最开始，最最开始。1492 年，哥伦布抵达新大陆。在今天的美国和加拿大，有多少原住民？可能在 300 到 400 万左右。一些历史学家会认为高达 700 或 800 万。但这个数字在接下来的几个世纪里急剧下降，主要是因为疾病，而不是因为战役、战斗之类的，特别是天花。纳税的美国殖民者扩张，他们变得独立并向西扩张，疾病显然随之传播，原住民的数量继续崩溃，所以到 1800 年代初，可能剩下不到 75 万，而且现在还在迅速下降。
you compare that with the population of european settlers and afric African slaves and their descendants, that number is surging from about 5 million in 1800 to about 25 million in 1850. So at the heart of this story is a massive demographic mismatch. The native peoples are totally outnumbered. But also Dominic, a movement west, right? And a movement west, exactly. And the more westwards you move, the more the mismatch widens because by 1860 i read an estimate there were 1.4 million euro americans in the trans-mississippi west by 1890 an estimated 8.5 million yeah so that sense of a tidal wave of people moving westwards totally
你把它与欧洲定居者和非洲奴隶及其后裔的人口相比，这个数字从 1800 年的约 500 万激增到 1850 年的约 2500 万。所以这个故事的核心是一个巨大的人口失衡。原住民的人数完全处于劣势。但多米尼克，还有一个向西的运动，对吧？确实是一个向西的运动。而且你越往西走，失衡就越严重，因为到 1860 年，我读到的一项估计显示，密西西比河以西有 140 万欧美移民，到 1890 年估计有 850 万。是的，所以那种向西移动的人潮，完全
kind of submerging and swamping the plains the peoples of the plains yeah The sense of it being like an unstoppable natural phenomenon almost, although of course it isn't. Now, a really important thing for people to get into their heads is that there is no sense of unity whatsoever among the native peoples of North America. So those people who listen to our podcast about Cortez and the fall of the Aztecs will remember that the people of Miso, America spent all their time fighting among themselves. There was no sense of unity against the Spaniards. And it's exactly the same story. They don't think of themselves as Indians. They don't think of themselves as part of a common ethnicity because nevermind, they're not, they're not at all. They're big rivals. You
淹没了平原，平原上的人民。是的，那种感觉就像一种不可阻挡的自然现象，尽管当然并非如此。现在，人们需要记住的一个非常重要的事情是，北美原住民之间根本没有任何统一感。所以那些听过我们关于科尔特斯（Cortez）和阿兹特克帝国灭亡的播客的人会记得，中美洲的人民把所有时间都花在自相残杀上。他们对西班牙人没有任何统一感。这完全是同一个故事。他们不认为自己是印第安人。他们不认为自己属于一个共同的种族，因为别介意，他们根本不是。他们是巨大的竞争对手。你
know, if you're a Pawnee or something, your big rivals are the people over the next hill that you're fighting for hunting grounds with, not the white are the people over the next hill that you're fighting for hunting grounds with, not the white settlers far away on the coast. But don't you think, I mean, I entirely accept that, but that by the 1860s or 1870s, there is a sense on the part of the various peoples who are living in the Great Plains, who are not white, that the white settlers are a kind of quantum difference? I think possibly by that stage, yes. And certainly among some of the more farsighted leaders who will come to a grade called Red
知道，如果你是波尼人（Pawnee）之类的，你的主要竞争对手是隔壁山头那些和你争夺狩猎场的人，而不是远在海岸的白人定居者。但你不认为，我的意思是，我完全接受这一点，但到了 1860 年代或 1870 年代，生活在大平原上的各种非白人族群是否有一种感觉，即白人定居者是一种质的差异？我想到了那个阶段可能是的。当然，在后来被称为“红云”（Red Cloud）的一些更有远见的领导人中，确实有人说，听着，嘿，这些白人，他们不仅仅是另一个变量。是的。他们不像我们。他们不是另一个部落。他们是一个变革性的因素。尽管反对这一点，我的意思是，这个故事中非常引人注目的一点是，各种美洲原住民愿意多么乐意与美国人结盟来
Cloud later, there are people who say, listen, hey, these white people, they're not just another variable. Yeah. They're not like us. They're not another tribe. They're a transformative factor. Although against that, I mean, one of the really noticeable things of this story is how readily various Native American peoples are willing to side with the Americans to do
打压他们的竞争对手。是的，非常重要，汤姆。所以无论美国骑兵或美国步兵去哪里，他们都有美洲原住民向导。绝对是。我们在上一集谈到了威奇托河大屠杀中的奥塞奇（Osage）侦察兵。正如你所说，他们总是有盟友。
down their rivals. Yeah. Massively important, Tom. So wherever the American cavalry are going or American infantry, they're being guided by Native American guides. Absolutely. We talked in the last episode about Osage scouts at the Wichita River Massacre. They always, as you say, have allies.
有些人倾向于站在美国一边。所以克罗人（Crows）或波尼人，他们经常与美国人结盟。实际上还有拉科塔苏族。是的，他们是盟友，不是吗？从 19 世纪初开始。是的，你是绝对正确的。所以 19 世纪上半叶有很多白人移民穿过大平原，他们说如果没有拉科塔人的帮助，他们永远无法成功。
There are some who sort of tend to side with the United States. So the Crows or the Pawnee, they're often allied with the Americans. And actually the Lakota Sioux. Yeah, they're allies, aren't they? From the beginning of the 19th century. Yeah, you're absolutely right. So there are lots of white emigrants going across the Great Plains in the first half of the 19th century who say that they would never have made it
是的。还有另一件事让这个故事变得非常复杂。所以你的那种“神圣精神”、那种“大地在哭泣”之类的东西，假设美洲原住民有一种固定性。这些是我们的祖先土地。它们几代人以来对我们来说都是神圣的。
without the help of the Lakota. Yeah. And the other thing that makes this a really complicated story. So you're sort of, your sacred spirits, kind of the earth cries out or whatever sort of stuff assumes a fixedness on the part of the earth cries out or whatever sort of stuff, assumes a fixedness on the part of the Native Americans. These are our ancestral lands. They've been sacred to us for generations.
那全是胡说八道。每个人都是移民。所以所有这些人都是定居者和征服者。他们都四处迁徙。我们上次谈到夏延人（Cheyenne）从明尼苏达州的森林迁徙过来。拉科塔人的故事完全一样。所以记住这种场景的流动性非常重要，大平原是一个广阔的区域，人们在四处走动，他们在战斗，没有人被困在同一个地方。
That is all tosh. Everybody is a migrant. So all of these people are settlers and conquerors. They have all moved around. We talked about the Cheyenne last time having moved from the woods of Minnesota. That's exactly the same story with the Lakota. So it's really important to remember the kind of fluidity of the scene, that the Great Plains are this great expanse where people are moving around and they're fighting and nobody's stuck in the same place.
并且互相掠夺土地。并且互相掠夺土地。每个人都是征服者。战争就是方式。好吧，那么 1776 年，当新的美国诞生时，它打算如何处理西部所有这些民族？答案是起初，他们签署了许多条约。然后他们撕毁了它们。是的。如果你去华盛顿的美洲印第安人博物馆，有一个关于条约的巨大展览，所有这些条约最终都被打破了，有时是蓄意的，但有时也因为，坦率地说，条约被证明已经过时了，因为一大波定居者到达了，联邦政府做出了
And stealing each other's land. And stealing each other's land. Everybody's a conqueror. War is the way. Okay, so 1776, when the new United States is born, how does it propose to deal with all of these peoples to the West? The answer is at first, they sign lots of treaties. And then they break them. Yeah. If you go to the Museum of the American Indian in Washington, there's a huge exhibition about treaties, all of which they end up breaking, sometimes willfully, but also sometimes because, frankly, the treaty proves outdated because a huge wave of settlers arrives and the federal government make a
非常软弱和敷衍的尝试来约束他们，结果完全徒劳。我的意思是，那是美国独立战争的很大一部分，不是吗？是的。他们不想被约束。英国人试图维护条约，说你不能走那么远。是的。而美国定居者只是不断地无视它。
very sort of feeble and half-hearted attempt to restrain them and it ends up completely futile. I mean, that was a huge part of the American War of Independence, wasn't it? It was. They didn't want to be restrained. The British were trying to uphold treaty that said you can't go so far. Yeah. And the American settlers just kept ignoring it.
然后在 1830 年代左右，出现了一种与安德鲁·杰克逊（Andrew Jackson）总统密切相关的策略转变。有一种被称为非常委婉的“迁移”（removal）政策。我们可能称之为实际上是种族清洗。所以这是要把乔克托人（Choctaws）、奇卡索人（Chickasaws）、克里克人（Creeks）、切罗基人（Cherokees）、塞米诺尔人（Seminoles）等部落，物理上迁移到数百英里外的西部，密西西比河以西，把他们全部赶出密西西比河以东的地区。如果我们基本上把 30 万原住民扔到密西西比河以西，那么剩下的所有土地就都是我们的了。
Then in the sort of, let's say the 1830s or so, there's a change attack associated very much with President Andrew Jackson. There's a policy of what is called, very euphemistically, removal. We might call it actually ethnic cleansing. So this is to take tribes like the Choctaws, the Chickasaws, the Creeks, the Cherokees, the Seminoles, and to physically move them hundreds of miles to the west, west of the Mississippi, get them all out of the area east of the Mississippi. If we basically dump 300,000 natives west of the Mississippi, then all the rest of the land will be for us.
当时人们说，从长远来看这会奏效，因为实际上，我们为什么要到大平原去？那里什么都没有。没有意义。它不适合人类居住。所以他们谈论一个永久的印第安边境，这条从明尼苏达延伸到路易斯安那的堡垒链，他们说西边的所有东西，让他们拥有吧。我们不在乎。但显然几乎立刻就崩溃了，因为首先，人们想修建小径去俄勒冈和加利福尼亚等等。博兹曼小径（Bozeman Trail）。我想那是我的顶级小径。是的，博兹曼小径，我们会谈到俄勒冈和加利福尼亚等等。博兹曼小径。
And at the time, people say, well, this will work in the long run because actually, why would we even want to go to the Great Plains? There's nothing there. There's no point. It's not suitable for human settlement. So they talk of a permanent Indian frontier, this chain of forts that goes from Minnesota to Louisiana, and they say everything to the west of that, let them have it. We don't care. But obviously almost straight away that collapses because, first of all, people want to build trails to get to Oregon and California and so on. The Bozeman Trail. I think that's my top trail. Yeah, the Bozeman Trail we'll come to Oregon and California and so on. The Bozeman Trail.
我想那是我的顶级小径。是的，博兹曼小径，我们会谈到。这是你最喜欢的小径。是的。然后，当然，你有了淘金热。所以 1848 年，在美墨战争期间，当美国将获得大量领土时，在加利福尼亚发现了黄金。
I think that's my top trail. Yeah, the Bozeman Trail we'll come to. It's your favorite trail. Yeah. And then, of course, you get the gold rushes. So 1848, in the middle of the Mexican-American War, when the United States is going to acquire a lot of territory, gold is discovered in California.
你有了大规模移民。所以此时，人们开始乘坐驿马车和马车队以及所有这些东西出发。当然，后来会有铁路穿过大平原。所以在那一点上，大平原突然又回到了桌面上。原住民不想让所有这些人穿过他们的土地去加利福尼亚淘金。所以当乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特（George Armstrong Custer）长大时，也就是 1840 年代，焦点已经从东海岸非常多地转移到了平原。正如我们所说，平原是一个充满持续战争、征服和战斗的广阔景观
You get mass migration. So at this point, people are setting off in stagecoaches and wagon trains and all these kinds of things. And of course, later on, there will be railroads going across the Great Plains. And so at that point, the Great Plains is suddenly back on the table. The native people don't want all these people coming through their lands to get to the gold of California. So by the time that George Armstrong Custer is growing up, which is the 1840s, the focus has moved from the East Coast very much to the Plains. And as we said, the Plains is this vast landscape of constant warfare and conquest and battles
为了狩猎场。那里人民的文化因马的到来而改变。所以西奥（Theo）在上一集中非常热衷于指出是欧洲人把马带到了美国。尽管当然，最初马是美国的。我知道，那不是很奇怪吗？那么马在此期间发生了什么，汤姆？它们灭绝了。然后它们又回来了。
for hunting grounds. The culture of the peoples there has been transformed by the arrival of the horse. So Theo was very keen that in the last episode that we point out that it's Europeans who brought the horse to America. Although of course, originally the horse was American. I know, isn't that weird? So what happened to the horses in the meantime, Tom? They went extinct. And then they returned.
是的。马的回归。马的回归。无论如何，马回来了。然后你有了大规模野牛狩猎的兴起。所以如果没有马，那是不可能的。不。所以野牛狩猎的习惯改变了，因为在 18 世纪，它仍然非常多地是一种把野牛赶下悬崖的习惯。但到了 19 世纪，他们可以骑马奔驰，使用他们的枪。所以他们正在以欧洲人的方式猎杀野牛。区别显然是规模巨大、巨大。是的，当然。但他们是，我的意思是，后来当欧洲的需求，
Yeah. The return of the horse. Return of the horse. Anyway, the horse returned. And so then you get the rise of big scale buffalo hunting. So that wouldn't have been possible without horses. No. And so the habit of buffalo hunting changes because in the 18th century, it's still very much a habit of chasing buffalo over cliffs. But by the 19th century, they can gallop along, use their guns. So they are killing buffalo in the way that Europeans will. The difference obviously is one of massive, massive scale. Yeah, of course. But they are, I mean, later on when the European demand,
或者说资本主义对皮革的需求，我们应该说，变得极其高涨，不仅是因为人们想要它用于传送带和工厂，那么往往是平原印第安人进行了大量的屠杀。他们实际上被整合到了某种贸易结构中。尽管，汤姆，我必须说，有一些关于白人定居者的绝对可怕的故事……哦，太可怕了。太可怕了。你知道，火车会在平原上隆隆作响。
or the sort of the capitalist demand, should we say, for leather goes off the charts, not least because people want it for conveyor belts and factories, then it's often Plains Indians who do a lot of the killing. They are actually integrated within the kind of trading structure. Although, Tom, I have to say there are some absolutely terrible stories about white settlers kind of. Oh, it's horrendous. It's horrendous. You know, the train would kind of rattle along the plains.
人们会探出窗外，只是对经过的野牛进行随机射击。是的。枪变得太热了，他们再也拿不住了。我的意思是，屠杀的规模是可怕的。是的。与旅鸽（passenger pigeon）一起，是北美大规模灭绝的伟大悲剧之一。
People would be leaning out of the window, just taking random pot shots at passing buffalo. Yes. The guns get so hot that they can't hold them anymore. Yeah. I mean, the scale of the slaughter is horrendous. Yes. Up there with the passenger pigeon as one of the great tragedies of mass extinction in North America.
是的。你感受到了这些，不是吗？非常敏锐地。非常非常敏锐地。我的意思是，你能想象看到野牛群在平原上奔涌吗？我去黄石公园纯粹是为了能在野外看到野牛。我的意思是，当我说是野外时，我宽松地使用了这个词。是的。你去了吗？是的，我去了。哦，那很好。好吧，无论如何，我们继续讲故事。
Yeah. You feel these things, don't you? Very keenly. Very, very keenly. I mean, can you imagine seeing buffalo herds surging over the plains? I went to Yellowstone purely so that I could see buffalo in the wild. I mean, when I say wild, I use the term loosely. Yeah. Did you? Yeah, I did. Oh, that's nice. Well, anyway, we'll crack on with the story.
我不想让它演变成伤感的度假回忆。无论如何，再次强调一点。彼得·考辛斯（Peter Cousins）在他的书《大地在哭泣》（The Earth Lies Weeping）中做得非常出色。他说，大平原的巨大讽刺是，军队将与之发生冲突的所有部落
I don't want it to generate into maudlin holiday reminiscences. Anyway, again, a point worth emphasising. Peter Cousins does this brilliant in his book, The Earth Lies Weeping. He says, the grand iron in the Great Plains is that none of the tribes with which the army would clash
都不是他们所声称的土地的原住民。这一点怎么强调都不为过。印第安人与大平原政府之间即将发生的战争，即最长、最血腥的斗争的所在地，代表了移民民族之间的冲突。
were native to the lands they claimed. This cannot be overemphasized. The wars that were to come between the Indians and the government of the Great Plains, the seat of the longest and bloodiest struggles, represented a clash of emigrant peoples.
一种生活方式消失了，但它并不是一种持续时间很长的方式。所以这很令人惊讶，因为我们不那样想。我们被制约了，不是吗？认为它是工业现代性与一种永恒、不变的生活方式之间的冲突。是的，那一点也不真实。而且它改变了，因为，嗯，让我们现在关注被称为苏族（Sioux）的人。但它改变了，因为他们是
A way of life was lost, but it had not been one of long duration. So that's quite surprising because we don't think of it that way. We're conditioned, aren't we, to think of it as a clash between industrial modernity and a timeless, unchanging way of life. Yeah, that couldn't be less true. And it's changed both because, well, let's focus in on the people called the Sioux now. But it's changed because they are
移民。他们从东部迁徙到西部。但也正如我们所说，他们有马和枪，而且他们以一种以前根本不会有的方式使用它们，因为以前他们有点在森林里闲逛。他们确实是。实际上，关于他们的一切都非常复杂，甚至名字也是。所以名字是错的，不是吗？名字来自……它有点法语，不是吗？
migrants. They have moved from the East to the West. But also, as we're saying, they have horses and guns, and they are using them in a way that they simply wouldn't have done before because previously they were kind of hanging out in forests. They were. Actually, everything about them is very complicated, even the name. So the name is wrong, isn't it? The name comes from… It's kind of French, isn't it?
它是法语，法国人是从一些被称为奥吉布瓦人（Ojibwa）的人那里听到的。他们讨厌他们。并称他们为蛇。它基本上意味着蛇，坏人。坏人，是的。实际上是苏族，我的意思是，我们仍然会使用这个词，因为一些苏族人已经重新启用了这个词，并说他们确实想使用它。所以再次，它有点被争议之类的。
It's come French, and the French heard it from some people called the Ojibwa. Who hated them. And called them the snakes. It basically means the snakes, the bad guys. The bad guys, yeah. And actually it's the Sioux, I mean, we'll still use the word, because some Sioux have reclaimed the word and say they do want to use it. So again, it's kind of contested and stuff.
他们是戴着被认定为美洲原住民的鹰羽头饰的人。是的。他们是那种范式的、刻板印象的美洲原住民。他们是。所以盖伊·吉本（Guy Gibbon），他写了一部精彩的苏族历史，对于世界上大多数人来说，印第安人的象征就是苏族的鹰羽头饰。甚至北美各地的其他印第安人在 powwows（印第安聚会）上也会佩戴这种头饰的某种版本，作为印第安统一的象征。
They are the people who wear the eagle feather headdress that is identified with Native Americans. Yeah. They are the sort of paradigmatic, stereotypical Native Americans. They are. So Guy Gibbon, who wrote a brilliant history of the Sioux, for most people in the world, the very symbol of Indianness is the Sioux eagle feather headdress. Even other Indian people throughout North America wear some version of this headdress at powwows as a symbol of Indian unity.
所以这意味着西方对苏族作为美洲原住民原型的感觉，是其他美洲原住民出于文化原因而采用的一种感觉。是的，那不是很奇怪吗？这正是故事有多复杂的例子。是的，它很复杂。所以正如你所说，他们某种程度上不在，正如所说的，在一个垂直的、正确的位置。顺便说一句，对于记得阿兹特克播客的人来说，
So what that implies is that the Western sense of the Sioux as the archetype of Native Americans is one that other Native Americans have kind of adopted for cultural reasons. Yeah, isn't that weird? Which is kind of example of how complex the story is. Yeah, it is complex. So as you were saying, they're kind of not in, as it were, in a vertical, the right place. By the way, for people who remember the Aztec podcast,
那对墨西加人（Mexica）来说也是真的，不是吗？是的，他们向南迁徙了，不是吗？他们向南迁徙了。所以他们最初在明尼苏达州和威斯康星州北部，所以离加拿大边境的大湖区并不远，尽管这对当时的他们来说是一个毫无意义的描述。然后他们向南移动，分成了三个群体，达科他人（Dakota）、纳科他人（Nakota）和拉科他人（Lakota）。
that was true of the Mexica as well, wasn't it? Yeah, they'd migrated southwards, hadn't they? They had migrated southwards. So they had originally been in Minnesota and northern Wisconsin, so not that far from the Great Lakes on the border with Canada, although that would have been a meaningless description to them then. And then they've moved south and they've divided into three groups, the Dakota, the Nakota, and the Lakota.
嗯，这都是同一个词，不是吗？这只是一种语言变体，方言。这只是方言，不是吗？而拉科他人是最著名的。所以他们是最大的群体，他们向被称为达科他地区以及蒙大拿州和怀俄明州的地方移动。他们是那种，你知道，当你想到苏族人骑着马，正如你所说的，汤姆，向野牛开枪时，那就是拉科他人。他们自己也分成了七个群体，我们称之为部落。虽然再次，那个词是一个相当沉重的词。它是。让我们使用部落。
Well, it's all the same word, isn't it? It's just kind of linguistic variants, dialect. It's just dialect, isn't it? And the Lakota are the most famous. So they're the biggest group and they move towards the place called the Dakotas and also Montana and Wyoming. And they are the people who are kind of, you know, when you think of the Sioux riding around on horses, as you said, Tom, kind of firing their rifles at bison, that's the Lakota. And they themselves are divided into seven groups, which we call tribes. Though again, that word is quite a loaded word. It is. Let's use tribe.
好的。但要认识到，它再次投射了欧洲的刻板印象。所以旁边有一个隐形的星号，汤姆。这就是我们要做的吗？带着一个隐形的星号。是的。那七个部落被称为奥格拉拉人（Oglalas）、布鲁莱人（Brulés）、米尼孔朱人（Miniconjus）、图克特尔人（Touquettles）、洪克帕帕人（Hunkpapas）、黑脚人（Blackfeet）和桑斯-阿克人（Sans-Arcs）。桑斯-阿克人？是的。
Okay. But with a recognition that it is, again, projecting European stereotypes. So with an invisible asterisk next to it, Tom. Is that what we're doing? With an invisible asterisk. Yes. And those seven tribes are called the Oglalas, the Brulés, the Miniconjus, the Touquettles, the Hunkpapas, the Blackfeet, and the Sans-Arcs. Sans-Arcs? Yeah.
那听起来一点也不像法语。或者确实是布鲁莱。布鲁莱，是的。我的意思是，再次，一切都通过白人的描述过滤。嗯，所以奥格拉拉和疯马的奥格拉拉，在一些美国文件中拼写为 O-Gallala，有传言说他们可能是爱尔兰血统。我看到了。尽管有趣的是，卡斯特认为他们是以色列人。卡斯特。疯了。
That doesn't sound French in any way. Or indeed the brûlée. The brûlée, yeah. I mean, again, everything is kind of filtered through the white people's descriptions. Well, so Ogallala and crazy horses Ogallala, it was spelt in some American documents, O-Gallala, and there was talk that perhaps they were of Irish extraction. I saw that. Although interestingly, Custer thought that they were Israelites. Custer. Bonkers.
在《我在平原上的生活》（My Life on the Plains）的开头，他有这种疯狂的即兴发挥，谈到美国原住民显然是以色列人。你在 19 世纪哪里都去不了，不是吗？我知道。没有傻瓜告诉你你遇到的人实际上是失落的以色列部落之类的。是的，嗯，他就是这么想的。所以拉科他人，他们绝不是一个自上而下的民族国家。他们没有某种中央权威。他们非常分散。
In the beginning of My Life on the Plains, he has this kind of mad riff where he talks about how the native peoples of America are clearly Israelites. You can't go anywhere in the 19th century, can you? I know. Without some fool telling you that the people you've met are actually the lost tribe of Israel or something like that. Yeah, well, that's what he thought. So the Lakotas, they're not a top-down nation state by any stretch of the imagination. They don't have a kind of central authority. They're very decentralized.
这在意识形态上对他们吸引力的一部分，比如对现在的美国无政府主义者或某种激进分子来说，不是吗？是的，绝对是。那种，你知道，他们完全分散的感觉。尽管在某些方面，他们对非常进步的人来说并不是很好的榜样。德国探险家马克西米利安·维德亲王（Prince Maximilian Wied）在 1833 年沿密苏里河旅行，汤姆，甚至他也感到非常震惊。他认为他们在性别关系上相当倒退。他说，妇女必须做所有的工作，而男人在提供食物后过着非常轻松舒适的生活。
And that is a crucial part of the appeal of them ideologically for, say, anarchists or kind of radicals in America at the moment, isn't it? It is, absolutely. The sense of, you know, that they are completely decentralized. Although in some ways they're not terribly good role models for very progressive people. The German explorer, Prince Maximilian Wied, traveled up the Missouri in 1833, Tom, and even he was quite struck. He thought they were quite regressive in their gender relations. He said, the women have to do all the work and the men lead a very easy and comfortable life once they have provided food.
他们整天坐着，抽烟斗或悠闲地走来走去。嗯，所以在某些方面不进步，但在其他方面相当进步，正如我们也许在适当的时候谈到性别关系的另一个方面时会看到的那样。我非常期待。所以战争对他们来说非常重要。
They sit about all day, smoke their pipes or walk about leisurely. Well, so in some ways not progressive, but in other ways quite progressive, as we'll see perhaps in due course when we come to another aspect of gender relations. I very much look forward to it. So war is enormously important to them.
他们一直在战斗。他们有固定的盟友，特别是夏延人和阿拉帕霍人（Arapahos）。他们有固定的敌人。所以他们鄙视的人远比白人美国人多。他们无法忍受波尼人。或者克罗人。还有克罗人。他们讨厌克罗人。
They are fighting all the time. They have regular allies, particularly the Cheyenne and the Arapahos. They have regular enemies. So the people they absolutely despise far more than white Americans. They can't stand the Pawnees. Or the crows. And the crows. They hate the crows.
克罗人有非常长的头发。他们确实有。他们用熊油润滑它。熊油。是的。想象一下。你认为那会有味道吗？当然，如果你是克罗人，就不会。
The crows have incredibly long hair. They do. And they oil it with bear grease. Bear grease. Yeah. Imagine that. Do you think that would smell? Not if you're a crow, of course.
但与卡斯特和他的润发油有一个迷人的平行之处。那是真的。还有他“肉桂”（Cinnamon）的绰号。肉桂。是的。所以实际上他们应该因为对油脂的热爱而建立联系。无论如何。嗯，他们某种程度上确实建立了联系，不是吗？
But a fascinating parallel with Custer with his pomade. That's true. And his nickname of Cinnamon. Cinnamon. Yeah. So actually they should have bonded over their love of grease. Anyway. Well, they kind of do, don't they?
我的意思是，克罗人最终和卡斯特一起骑马。那是真的。是的。也许这是一个被低估的因素。平原上不断变化的忠诚度，汤姆。护发产品是让他们联系在一起的东西。有一篇关于这个的精彩文章。它根本没有提到护发产品。
I mean, the crows end up kind of riding with Custer. That's true. Yeah. Maybe this is an underappreciated element. The shifting loyalties of the plains, Tom. Haircare products is what bonded them. There's a great article on this. It doesn't mention haircare products at all.
它是由一个叫理查德·怀特（Richard White）的人在 1978 年写的，它在美洲原住民研究领域是绝对变革性的。它被称为《西部的征服》（The Winning of the West）。他基本上说，听着，我们把拉科塔人完全搞错了，把他们视为被动的受害者。事实上，把所有这些平原印第安人视为美国扩张的被动受害者。他们自己也是无情扩张的人民，有着非常深刻的感觉。也许民族认同不是完全正确的词，但真正激励他们的是这种扩张狩猎场的无情动力。而拉科他人正在取代克罗人，不是吗？他们是。实际上，他们非常清楚这一点。有一个叫黑鹰（Black Hawk）的人在
It was written in 1978 by a guy called Richard White, and it was absolutely transformative in the world of Native American studies. It was called The Winning of the West. And he basically said, listen, we've got the Lakota all wrong in sort of seeing them as passive victims. And indeed, seeing all these Plains Indians as passive victims of American expansion. They are ruthlessly expansionist people themselves with a very profound sense. Maybe national identity is not quite the right word, but what really animates them is this relentless drive to expand their hunting grounds. And the Lakota are displacing the Crow, aren't they? They are. And actually, they're very conscious of this. There's a guy called Black Hawk who says to
19 世纪中期对一位美国官员说，他说，这些土地曾经属于克罗人，但我们把那些民族从那里赶走了。在这方面，我们做了白人在想要印第安人土地时所做的事情。那太迷人了。是的，那太迷人了。所以有一种感觉，我们是游戏的赢家，现在我们处于失败的一方。但拉科他人也在某种意义上与白人拥有的优势相平行，即他们都接种了疫苗，不是吗？针对许多疾病。他们接种了，通过传教士。克罗人没有。所以克罗人全部被消灭了，他们的人数骤减，
an American official in the mid-19th century, he says, these lands once belonged to the Crows, but we whipped those nations out of them. And in this, we did what white men do when they want the lands of the Indians. That's fascinating. Yeah, that is fascinating. So there's a sort of sense where we were winners of the game and now we're on the losing side. But another way in which the Lakota are also, in a sense, kind of paralleling the advantages that the whites have is that they had all been inoculated, hadn't they, against a lot of diseases. They had, by missionaries. The crows hadn't. So the crows all get wiped out, their numbers plummet,
而拉科他人能够进入并取代他们。没错。而且他们的一些竞争对手，比如波尼人，稍微更定居一些。他们更倾向于农业。这意味着天花可以扎根并摧毁一个定居点。拉科他人四处走动，他们更游牧。所以实际上天花并没有像在其他人身上那样在他们身上扎根。所以再次，这给了他们很大的优势。而且它助长了拉科他人对农民的蔑视。是的。
and the Lakota are able to move in and displace them. That's right. And also some of their rivals, like the Pawnee, are a little bit more sedentary. They're more agricultural. And that means that smallpox can sort of take hold and will destroy a settlement. The Lakota are moving around, they're more nomadic. So actually smallpox doesn't take hold with them in the same way that it does with some of the others. So again, that gives them a big advantage. And it feeds into the Lakota contempt for farmers. Yes.
对于定居民族，这也是故事的重要组成部分。完全正确。所以问题是，美国政府将如何处理拉科他人？1851 年，他们在怀俄明州的拉勒米堡（Fort Laramie）签署了一项条约。基本上，这项条约说，你们将停止与其他人战斗。你们不会与我们战斗。你们将允许我们在你们的领土上修建道路和堡垒。你们不会骚扰我们的先驱之类的。
For sedentary peoples, which is also an important part of the story. Totally. So the question is, how are the US government going to deal with the Lakota? And in 1851, they signed a treaty at Fort Laramie in Wyoming. And basically, this treaty said, you'll stop fighting other people. You won't fight us. You'll allow us to build roads and forts through your territory. You won't molest our pioneers and stuff.
博兹曼小径，多米尼克。我知道你渴望谈论博兹曼。它是什么？只是关于名字的一些东西。开车穿过蒙大拿州，看到博兹曼，充满了美国西部的浪漫。好的。好吧，我们会在适当的时候谈到博兹曼先生。根据条约，美洲原住民应该做所有这些，表现得非常好。另一方面，政府说，我们将保护你们免受白人定居者的侵害。我们将支付你们年金。我们将提供物资和所有这些东西。
The Bozeman Trail, Dominic. I know you're desperate to talk about the Bozeman. What is it? It's just something about the name. It was driving through Montana and seeing Bozeman, full of the romance of the American West. Okay. Well, we'll come to Mr. Bozeman in due course. So under the treaty, the Native Americans are supposed to do all this, be very nice. On the other hand, the government say, we will shield you from white settlers. We'll pay you annuities. We'll give you supplies and all this stuff.
嗯，1851 年的这项条约完全是一个虚构。首先，平原印第安人根本没有打算停止战斗或尊重美国人要求他们遵守的边界。另一方面，联邦政府……内战，有大量的矿工涌入，有在俄勒冈小径和所有其他小径上旅行的人。所以有那个。然后在 1862 年，多米尼克，在蒙大拿州发现了黄金。没错。博兹曼小径开始了。不仅如此，汤姆，1862 年，国会通过了《宅地法》（Homestead Act）。所以这是在内战期间的亚伯拉罕·林肯领导下。这基本上说，如果你去西部，在某块土地上住五年，它就是你的了。
Well, this treaty in 1851 is a total and utter fiction. First of all, the Plains Indians have absolutely no intention of stopping fighting or respecting the boundaries that the Americans are asking them to keep to. And on the other hand, the federal government the Civil War, there was a huge influx of miners, of people traveling on the Oregon Trail and all these other trails. So there's that. And then in 1862, Dominic, gold is discovered in Montana. Right. And the Bozeman Trail kicks off. And not only that, Tom, in 1862, Congress passed the Homestead Act. So this is under Abraham Lincoln in the Civil War. And this basically says, if you go out west and you live on some land for five years, it is yours.
嗯，1851年的这份条约完全是彻头彻尾的虚构。首先，平原印第安人根本无意停止战斗，也不打算遵守美国人要求他们恪守的边界。另一方面，联邦政府正忙于内战，当时有大量矿工和沿俄勒冈小径及其他路径迁徙的人涌入。所以情况就是这样。接着在1862年，多米尼克，蒙大拿州发现了黄金，对吧？博兹曼小径随之开辟。不仅如此，汤姆，1862年国会还通过了《宅地法》。这是在亚伯拉罕·林肯领导下的内战期间，该法案基本上规定，如果你去西部并在某块土地上居住五年，那块土地就归你所有。
You can establish your homestead and it will be yours by right. And there's a huge flood of people during the Civil War. And actually, it's during the Civil War, the six new territories. So a territory is the kind of precursor of a state. You become a territory first, then you'll become an official United States state. And they are Nevada, Idaho, Arizona, Montana, Dakota, they're not divided into North and South, and Colorado. And through and to these new territories, there are stagecoach lines and telegraph lines. And of course, in due course, there will be railroads.
你可以建立自己的宅地，它将依法归你所有。内战期间，大量人口涌入。事实上，正是在内战期间，出现了六个新领地。领地是成为州的前身。你先成为领地，然后才能成为正式的美国州。它们是内华达、爱达荷、亚利桑那、蒙大拿、达科他（当时尚未分为南北）、以及科罗拉多。随着这些新领地的建立，驿站马车线路和电报线路也随之开通。当然，到了一定时候，铁路也会随之而来。
And this is the classic thing that is often repeated now as being an expression of anti-capitalism, the idea that you can own the earth. Because that is something very difficult. It is. Meaningless. I mean, it makes no sense at all that you can draw lines and say, I own this and you've got to keep out. Exactly. They can't get their heads around that at first. And it's only over time that they begin to realize what the implications of this are. So the expansion is coming, and this is obviously provoking great unrest and displeasure among the people of the plains. The other thing that happens in 1862, Tom, is that the Lakota win a big, big victory against the Crow. They whop them.
这是一种现在常被重复作为反资本主义表达的经典观点，即你可以拥有土地。因为这非常困难。确实如此。毫无意义。我的意思是，你可以划定界限说“这是我的，你必须离开”，这根本说不通。没错。他们起初无法理解这一点。直到后来，他们才开始意识到这意味着什么。所以扩张即将来临，这显然引起了平原人民极大的不安和不满。汤姆，1862年发生的另一件事是，拉科塔人在与克罗人的战斗中取得了巨大的胜利。他们彻底击败了他们。
They have been fighting for 20 years or so for a particular area called the Powder River Country, which is kind of prime hunting grounds. And in 1862, they finally get it under this bloke called Red Cloud, who's this very formidable, charismatic leader. The closest they have to a kind of paramount chief. He's their big strategist. But as you rightly said, in 1862, they find gold in Montanaana a man called mr bozeman right and he wants to have a trail to montana right through this territory and that the u.s government is going to build two forts fort kearney and fort smith to guard the trail and the forts are very disruptive for plains indians because you get like kind of shanty towns connected with the forts you get all
他们为了一个被称为“粉河地区”的特定区域已经战斗了大约20年，那里是绝佳的狩猎场。1862年，在一位名叫“红云”的人的领导下，他们终于夺取了该地区。红云是一位非常强大、富有魅力的领袖。他最接近于某种最高首领。他是他们伟大的战略家。但正如你所说，1862年，人们在蒙大拿发现了黄金，一个叫博兹曼的人想要开辟一条穿过这片领地的通往蒙大拿的道路，美国政府打算修建两座堡垒——卡尼堡和史密斯堡——来守卫这条道路。这些堡垒对平原印第安人来说非常具有破坏性，因为堡垒周围会出现棚户区，你会看到各种
the kind of the hangers, the camp hangers on. And it just basically destroys the ecosystem. Although, to look at it from the point of view of those who are in the forts, I mean, they are very, very isolated. Yeah. So both sides are feeling nervous of the other, which obviously doesn't foster good relations. Exactly.
各种各样的闲散人员，营地里的寄生虫。这基本上摧毁了生态系统。虽然从堡垒里的人的角度来看，他们确实非常、非常孤立。是的。所以双方都对对方感到紧张，这显然不利于建立良好的关系。没错。
So Red Cloud says, what? We've just conquered this land from the crows. And now, literally within weeks, you're going to come in and build your forts and all that business? No way. And he becomes the figurehead for, I'm not going to use the word uprising because I think it's too loaded. It's a war. It's called Red Cloud's War. It's not an uprising because they're not controlled by the US. That's their way of looking at it. It's a fair fight, Red Clouds War. Well, they fought the crow over territory and land and the right to hunt, and now they're fighting the Americans, I guess. Exactly. And he is the political face of this, and the military face is this guy called Crazy Horse. So Dominic, I think just at this point, let's take a break. And when we come back, we'll continue looking at this extraordinary culture, this embattled culture. But I mean, so fascinating. of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment
所以红云说，什么？我们刚从克罗人手中征服了这片土地。现在，仅仅几周之内，你们就要进来建造堡垒和搞那些名堂？没门。他成为了这场运动的领袖，我不想用“起义”这个词，因为我觉得它太沉重了。这是一场战争。它被称为“红云战争”。这不是起义，因为他们不受美国控制。这是他们的看法。这是一场公平的战斗，红云战争。好吧，他们为了领土、土地和狩猎权与克罗人战斗，现在我想他们是在与美国人战斗。没错。他是这场战争的政治门面，而军事门面是那个叫“疯马”的人。多米尼克，我想现在我们休息一下。回来后，我们将继续探讨这种非凡的、饱受战火蹂躏的文化。我的意思是，太迷人了。娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking about the Plains Indians.
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《其余皆历史》。我们正在谈论平原印第安人。
So, Tom, Crazy Horse. Now, Crazy Horse is a fantastic character. Crazy Horse was probably born in about 1840, and his name wasn't Crazy Horse at first, was it? It was... Curly. No, even before that, it was Among the Trees. Well, this is the difficult thing, isn't it,
那么，汤姆，疯马。疯马是一个了不起的人物。疯马大约出生于1840年，他起初不叫疯马，对吧？他叫……卷毛。不，在那之前，他叫“树丛中”。好吧，这就是困难所在，不是吗？
about following the lives of Native American heroes, is that their names are constantly changing. But also, so with Crazy Horse, everything that we will say now is sort of, I was about to say probably untrue. It's very contested. It's very muddled. Everything is filtered through white newspapermen, people who are giving interviews telling white audiences what they want to hear, folk tales, legends, all that stuff. of their kind of Christian framing of the universe is not something that is a part of the mental furniture of the Lakota. The supernatural is woven through the very fabric of everyday existence.
关于追踪美洲原住民英雄的生活，他们的名字在不断变化。而且，关于疯马，我们现在所说的一切，我正想说，可能是不真实的。它非常有争议。非常混乱。一切都经过白人报纸记者的过滤，这些人接受采访时告诉白人听众他们想听的内容，民间传说、传奇，所有这些东西。他们那种基督教式的宇宙观并不是拉科塔人思维的一部分。超自然现象贯穿于日常生活的方方面面。
And so visions and an interface with the supernatural is a part of every Native American story that is being told. And so in the life of someone like Crazy Horse, there'll be descriptions of him leading a war band and then suddenly having incredible visions. And the two are not distinguished. Yeah, I think that's right, Tom. If we were doing this podcast about Alexander the Great, we'd be telling all kinds of anecdotes about crazy things that had happened. Talking snakes and things. Talking snakes or whatever, exactly.
因此，幻象和与超自然的互动是每一个被讲述的美洲原住民故事的一部分。所以，在像疯马这样的人的生活中，会有关于他带领一支战队然后突然产生不可思议的幻象的描述。这两者并没有被区分开来。是的，我想你是对的，汤姆。如果我们是在做关于亚历山大大帝的播客，我们会讲述各种关于发生的疯狂事情的轶事。会说话的蛇之类的。会说话的蛇或其他什么，没错。
And it would be fine because almost everybody in that world, you know, you're using the same register for everyone in that world. The complicated thing with this is some of the characters, their lives are a compound of folk tales, myths, stories, as you say, about the sort of porous boundary between the natural and the supernatural. They feel like the stories of Greek heroes. And on the other hand, you've got somebody like Custer, you know, occupying the same space, but the register that we use, this sort of the historical idiom with which we discuss him is totally different. Well, and also the dimension of the supernatural is shot through with relationships to buffalo, to the rhythms of the year that are migratory. So aspects of life that depend on them not being confined within
这没问题，因为那个世界里的几乎每个人，你知道，你对那个世界里的每个人都使用相同的语境。这里复杂的地方在于，其中一些人物的生活是民间传说、神话、故事的混合体，正如你所说，关于自然与超自然之间那种多孔的界限。它们感觉就像希腊英雄的故事。另一方面，你又有像卡斯特这样的人，你知道，占据着同样的空间，但我们使用的语境，即我们讨论他时所用的历史习语是完全不同的。嗯，而且超自然的维度也与水牛、迁徙的季节节奏交织在一起。因此，那些依赖于不被限制在
reservations and made to live as farmers and take up christianity yeah so being penned in a reservation it's not just physical it's also psychological and cultural yeah i think that's absolutely right i think it's true okay let's go back to a crazy horse we don't know what he looked like because he never posed for a photograph it is said said, and of course it is said, he's doing a lot of lifting there, that he thought the camera would rob him of his soul. So we don't have any pictures of him. We do know that it was said that his hair was very light. People commented again and again, lighter than other Indians, when he had a kind of androgynous look to him. So when Indian agent described him as a bashful girlish looking boy so like custom being called fanny yeah and they're both called curly they are both called curly because he's called curly because of his curly sort of lightish hair there's a story in 1850 that he single-handedly tames this kind of formidable stallion i have to say this story sounds very alexander the great and therefore I raise an eyebrow a bit.
保留地内、被迫像农民一样生活并接受基督教的生活方式的各个方面。是的，所以被关在保留地里，不仅仅是身体上的，也是心理和文化上的。是的，我认为这绝对正确，我认为这是事实。好吧，让我们回到疯马。我们不知道他长什么样，因为他从未拍过照片。据说，当然是据说，他在其中发挥了很大作用，他认为相机可能会夺走他的灵魂。所以我们没有他的任何照片。我们确实知道，据说他的头发非常浅。人们一次又一次地评论说，他比其他印第安人更浅，他有一种雌雄同体的外表。所以当印第安代理人形容他为一个害羞的、看起来像女孩的男孩时，就像卡斯特被称为“范妮”一样。是的，他们都被称为“卷毛”，因为他被称为“卷毛”，因为他那卷曲的、浅色的头发。1850年有一个故事说他单枪匹马驯服了一匹强大的种马。我不得不说，这个故事听起来非常像亚历山大大帝，所以我有点怀疑。
And some people say this is when he gets a name, his horse stands looking. There's a lot of different anecdotes about how he gets his name, crazy horse. There's a lot of just so, isn't there? There's a lot, yeah. But we can get a sense of what his early life was like because we know what Lakota boys, what happened to them. And it's actually quite an intimidating routine
有些人说这就是他得到名字的时候，他的马站着看。关于他如何得到“疯马”这个名字，有很多不同的轶事。有很多“就是这样”，不是吗？有很多，是的。但我们可以了解他早年的生活是什么样的，因为我们知道拉科塔男孩经历了什么。这实际上是一个相当令人生畏的常规
they go through. So at five or six, they're being trained for war. That is the way of things. At five or six, you're made to run long distances. You have to swim streams. You're often deprived of food or water to kind of toughen you up. By about seven or eight, you've been given your first bow and arrows and you're told to shoot.'re trained to shoot you're trained to ride you would take part in your first raid when you're about 14 or 15 you would be expected by the time you're 18 to have stolen a horse to probably have taken a scalp we'll get on to scalping in just a second but you can opt out dominic yes so you were talking about how unprogressive the locota are in their gender relations. Yeah.
他们经历的过程。所以五六岁时，他们就开始接受战争训练。这就是事情的方式。五六岁时，你被迫进行长跑。你必须游泳过河。你经常被剥夺食物或水来磨练你。七八岁左右，你得到了第一把弓箭，并被告知要射击。你接受射击训练，接受骑马训练。你会在14或15岁左右参加第一次突袭。到18岁时，你会被期望已经偷了一匹马，可能已经取了一个头皮。我们稍后会谈到剥头皮，但你可以选择退出，多米尼克。是的，所以你刚才在谈论拉科塔人在性别关系上是多么不进步。是的。
But say you decide that the whole scalping... It's not for you. You know, it's not for you. This is your loophole, Tom. Your loophole is that you can put on a woman's dress and turn to cooking and things like that, and you become a winkte. A winkte. Which apparently is, it's a kind of contraction of a Lakota word,
但假设你决定整个剥头皮……不适合你。你知道，它不适合你。这是你的漏洞，汤姆。你的漏洞是你可以穿上女人的衣服，转而从事烹饪之类的事情，然后你成为一个“温克特”（winkte）。一个温克特。这显然是拉科塔语的一个缩写，
basically meaning a male who wants to be female. So a sort of Lakota Gordon Ramsay would have been a winktay. Well, he was actually a footballer first, wasn't he? So he'd have done both. Yeah, I don't think he'd have gone for that. No. Do you know, I think I probably would have gone for the winktay option. I knew you were gearing up for this.
基本上意味着一个想成为女性的男性。所以一个拉科塔版的戈登·拉姆齐会是一个温克特。嗯，他起初是个足球运动员，不是吗？所以他会两者都做。是的，我不认为他会选择那个。不。你知道吗，我想我可能会选择温克特选项。我知道你一直在为这个做准备。
What would you have gone for? Would you have gone for the whole scalping thing? I'm very conventional. I would have gone for the scalping, I think. But I'd have tried to move into kind of military intelligence as quickly as possible, if that were an option. A Lakota flashman. Exactly. Yeah.
你会选择什么？你会选择整个剥头皮的事情吗？我非常传统。我想我会选择剥头皮。但我会尝试尽快进入某种军事情报部门，如果那是可选的话。一个拉科塔版的弗莱什曼。没错。是的。
Thanks. Bluffing. Yes. So the hurdles that you cross, the most important one is this thing called counting coup. And basically, this does seem kind of a bit odd to me. But anyway, I'm not a a plains indian so no wonder it's really a mark of tremendous distinction and what you need to have done is basically touched an enemy with a very long stick and that's the highest war honor you get and actually what you want to do is you don't want to do it with a weapon because you know that's sort of less audacious.
谢谢。虚张声势。是的。所以你跨越的障碍，最重要的是这个叫做“计数战功”（counting coup）的事情。基本上，这对我来说似乎有点奇怪。但无论如何，我不是平原印第安人，所以难怪。这确实是一个巨大的荣誉标志，你需要做的是基本上用一根很长的棍子触碰敌人，这是你获得的最高战争荣誉。事实上，你想要做的是，你不想用武器去做，因为你知道那有点不那么大胆。
It's touching him with this stick, a live enemy, not trying to kill him, but basically almost tagging him, isn't it, Tom? Yeah. And to have done that when you've counted your first coup, that is seen as an absolutely tremendous thing and a really crucial step towards manhood. You've dared, basically, to ride up to a crow, sort of prod him with your stick and then ride away without him killing you. Meanwhile, I'm off picking berries. Of course you are. Now, the other thing you can do, which is kind of obviously always fascinating to us, but it's actually regarded as lesser than counting coo, is taking a scalp. And the way that works, that doesn't actually necessarily kill somebody.
这是用这根棍子触碰他，一个活着的敌人，不是试图杀死他，而是基本上几乎是标记他，不是吗，汤姆？是的。当你数了你的第一个战功时，这被视为一件绝对了不起的事情，也是迈向男子气概的一个非常关键的步骤。你基本上敢于骑马冲向一个克罗人，用你的棍子戳他，然后在他杀死你之前骑马离开。与此同时，我去采浆果了。你当然会。现在，你可以做的另一件事，显然对我们来说总是很迷人，但实际上被认为比“计数战功”低一等，那就是取一个头皮。它的运作方式是，那并不一定非要杀死某人。
I was surprised at this. No, it doesn't. So there's this guy, William Thompson, who's an Englishman. Yes. Yeah. I mean, so many Englishmen are going kind of you know they're obviously fascinated by going out there so there was that old etonian who got shot yeah mr williams but there's this guy william thompson who gets scalped um and he goes back to england and he makes a living kind of bending his head forward and showing off his scalp showing off his basically trepan the skull so the way that would work is someone would grab your hair they're're very long hair, and they make a kind of cut
我对此感到惊讶。不，它不需要。所以有一个叫威廉·汤普森的人，他是个英国人。是的。我的意思是，很多英国人都去那里，你知道，他们显然对去那里很着迷，所以有一个老伊顿公学学生被枪杀了，是的，威廉先生，但有一个叫威廉·汤普森的人被剥了头皮，他回到英国，靠低头展示他的头皮为生，展示他基本上被钻孔的头骨。所以它的运作方式是，有人会抓住你的头发，他们非常长的头发，然后他们做一个切口
around your skull, two or three inches, and then they literally pull it off. And there's apparently a huge popping sound, report like a pop gun, and then you might attach the scalps to your sort of horse or something, or you would hang them from your tent, and they would show what a tremendous fellow you were. It's kind of tougher with white people, isn't it?
绕着你的头骨，两三英寸，然后他们真的把它拉下来。显然会有一个巨大的爆裂声，像爆竹一样的报告声，然后你可能会把头皮挂在你的马或其他什么东西上，或者你会把它们挂在你的帐篷上，它们会显示你是一个多么了不起的人。这在白人身上更难，不是吗？
Yeah, because their hair's too short. Yeah. I mean, in my case, Tom, a potential scalper would have a very tough task. You know, we'll come to what happens to Custers. Yes. In due course. Very interesting. But if you did kill somebody, then the important thing is to mutilate their body, isn't it?
是的，因为他们的头发太短了。我的意思是，就我而言，汤姆，一个潜在的剥头皮者会有一个非常艰巨的任务。你知道，我们会谈到卡斯特发生了什么。是的。到适当的时候。非常有趣。但如果你确实杀死了某人，那么重要的事情是毁坏他们的身体，不是吗？
And that's not just for sadistic reasons. No, it's to stop them from functioning in the afterlife. Exactly. I mean, they'd really go to town. They'd take out the teeth. They'd cut off your chin. And your nose. Take off the joints of your fingers.
这不仅仅是出于施虐的原因。不，这是为了阻止他们在来世发挥作用。没错。我的意思是，他们真的会大干一场。他们会拔掉牙齿。他们会切掉你的下巴。还有你的鼻子。切掉你手指的关节。
Yeah. We've talked already about how your private parts get chopped off and left on rocks. Yes. Eyes get taken out, don't they? They do. And left. So, not fun. And actually, the fact that we are dwelling on that,
是的。我们已经谈过你的私处是如何被切掉并留在石头上的。是的。眼睛被挖出来，不是吗？是的。留在那儿。所以，不好玩。事实上，我们正在纠结于这一点，
we are part of a continuum that goes right the way back to Custer's age. Because everyone, all white Americans, for understandable reasons, particularly if they're actually out in the plains,
我们是追溯到卡斯特时代的一个连续体的一部分。因为每个人，所有的白人美国人，出于可以理解的原因，特别是如果他们真的在平原上，
are obsessed by this. But I mean, Custer, for instance, is fascinated by scalping. Yeah. He says it's, you know, Barbara Savage, but he is really,
都对此着迷。但我的意思是，卡斯特，例如，对剥头皮很着迷。是的，他说这是，你知道，野蛮的行径，但他确实，
really very interested in it as we are now. He is. Now, of course, we find it, I mean, it's always described in terms of this is a sign of savagery and sort of goriness and stuff, but obviously that's not how the Plains Indians themselves perceive it. So let's put it this way, Tom. I think to us, people with that kind of lazy decadence, it seems like a very demanding lifestyle.
真的非常感兴趣，就像我们现在一样。他是。现在，当然，我们发现它，我的意思是，它总是被描述为野蛮和血腥的标志，但显然平原印第安人自己并不是这样看待它的。所以让我们这样说，汤姆。我认为对我们这些有着那种懒散颓废的人来说，这看起来是一种非常苛刻的生活方式。
Definitely. But I imagine quite fun if you've been kind of raised and you're good at the whole taking scalps and tapping people with sticks and things. Yeah're and you're good at the whole taking scalps and uh tapping people with sticks and things yeah if you're good at it exactly very exciting oh it's definitely exciting and i think the fact it's fun and exciting is a massive massive part of it do you know what it is a massive part of it because this explains why younger men in particular are very reluctant to accept a new life on the reservations because they say hold on the older men are happy to accept a new life on the reservations. Because they say, hold on, the older men are happy to accept the new life on the reservations because they've had their fun and they've proved their manhood. We are being denied our chance to have adventures.
绝对。但我认为如果你从小被培养，并且擅长剥头皮和用棍子敲人等等，那会很有趣。是的，如果你擅长剥头皮和用棍子敲人等等，如果你擅长它，没错，非常令人兴奋。哦，它绝对令人兴奋，我认为它有趣且令人兴奋是其中非常非常重要的一部分。你知道吗，它是其中非常重要的一部分，因为这解释了为什么年轻人特别不愿意接受保留地的新生活，因为他们说，等等，年长的人很高兴接受保留地的新生活。因为他们说，等等，年长的人很高兴接受保留地的新生活，因为他们已经玩够了，证明了他们的男子气概。我们被剥夺了冒险的机会。
But I think it's more than just wanting to prove their manhood. I think it's the fact that it's physically exhilarating. It's a bit like people who object to having fox hunting banned, who are growing up. People want the chance to break their neck because without the chance of breaking the neck, the excitement is, I mean, it's not my kind of bag, but I can understand that. And I think that that is a crucial, crucial part of why they don't want to give it up. They enjoy it. No, and Crazy Horse certainly enjoys it. So they're all stories told about him when he's in his teens, seeing off grizzly bears, fighting arapahos, fighting crows and things.
但我认为这不仅仅是想证明他们的男子气概。我认为这是因为它在身体上令人振奋。这有点像那些反对禁止猎狐的人，他们正在成长。人们想要冒着摔断脖子的机会，因为如果没有摔断脖子的机会，这种兴奋感，我的意思是，这不是我的菜，但我可以理解。我认为这是他们不想放弃的一个至关重要的部分。他们享受它。不，疯马当然享受它。所以关于他十几岁时击退灰熊、与阿拉帕霍人战斗、与克罗人战斗等等的故事有很多。
And this is what gives him his name, Crazy Horse. Because his dad's called Crazy Horse, isn't he? That's right. And his dad at one point says, basically, I'm no longer Crazy Horse. I give the name to you. This is quite common. Now, the other thing that people say about him is he's not just brave, but they say he has he has medicine now
这就是他名字的由来，疯马。因为他爸爸叫疯马，不是吗？没错。他爸爸在某个时候说，基本上，我不再是疯马了。我把这个名字给你。这很常见。现在，人们关于他的另一件事是，他不仅勇敢，而且他们说他有“药”（medicine）。现在
this is such a mistranslation we talk about a medicine man and it sounds like a gp it does it sounds like they're walking around with painkillers your medicine is much more than that it is a kind of the force it is a force and it has an element of the um you read harry potter to your children you probably didn't did you no they have a a Patronus, which is like a spirit animal. Oh, as in like Philip Pullman? Kind of, a bit like that. Yeah, a little bit like that. So there's an element of that with these chaps.
这是一个多么糟糕的翻译。我们谈论“巫医”（medicine man），听起来像个全科医生。确实，听起来他们随身带着止痛药。你的“药”远不止于此，它是一种力量，它是一种力量，并且它有一个……你给你的孩子读《哈利·波特》吗？你可能没有，对吧？不，他们有一个守护神，就像灵兽一样。哦，就像菲利普·普尔曼的那样？有点像，有点像那样。所以这些家伙身上有那种元素。
So they would have a vision and a creature might appear to you and that becomes your medicine. And you would emulate your helper. So it might be an eagle and you have the swiftness of an eagle. Or it might be the cunning of a fox and you would paint that symbol on your shield. What do you think you'd have?
所以他们会有一个幻象，一个生物可能会出现在你面前，那就会成为你的“药”。你会效仿你的助手。它可能是一只鹰，你拥有鹰的敏捷。或者它可能是狐狸的狡猾，你会把那个符号画在你的盾牌上。你觉得你会拥有什么？
Deep down, I know it's a dog. There's no way of getting away from this. What would you have, Tom? Oh, a velociraptor. A velociraptor. I mean,
在内心深处，我知道是一条狗。这是无法逃避的。你会拥有什么，汤姆？哦，一只迅猛龙。一只迅猛龙。我的意思是，
you wouldn't be allowed that. Why not? Let's say you can have a bird of some kind, maybe. Okay. So the same period, you know, this is when paleontologists are going out. Oh, come on. We can't allow this to spout. So one of them will become big friends with Red Cloud.
你不会被允许那样做。为什么不？让我们说你可以拥有一种鸟，也许。好吧。同一时期，你知道，这是古生物学家出去的时候。哦，得了吧。我们不能允许这个喷涌而出。所以其中一个会成为红云的好朋友。
Right. Okay. Othniel Charles Marsh, and he'll become a big ally of Red Cloud in Washington. Is that so? Yeah. Well, we'll come to that. Okay. I think you'd have like a sparrow or something. Yeah. A meerkat. Right. Anyway, the vision that you have is a massively serious thing and actually has been greatly introduced by the kind of new agey way
好吧。奥斯尼尔·查尔斯·马什，他将成为红云在华盛顿的一大盟友。是这样吗？是的。好吧，我们会谈到那个。好吧。我想你会拥有一只麻雀之类的。是的。一只猫鼬。好吧。无论如何，你拥有的幻象是一件非常严肃的事情，实际上已经被那种新时代的方式极大地引入了
of talking about this. You would go for days without food and water. You would sit on a mountaintop or something. It's shamanistic, isn't it? It is. I mean, there's a guy, John Fire at a cota. He said, it hits you sharp and clear like an electric shock. You're wide awake.
谈论这个。你会几天不吃不喝。你会坐在山顶或其他什么地方。这是萨满教的，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，有一个叫约翰·火·拉科塔的人。他说，它像电击一样尖锐而清晰地击中你。你完全清醒。
Suddenly there's a person standing next to you who you know can't be there at all. You're not dreaming though. Your eyes are open. People would be desperate to have visions. And if they didn't have them, they would actually have to pay a medicine man for his medicine, for his supernatural powers. Crazy Horse undoubtedly has them. He has visions of thunderstorms, of being struck by lightning.
突然有一个人站在你旁边，你知道他根本不可能在那里。但你不是在做梦。你的眼睛是睁着的。人们会不顾一切地想要拥有幻象。如果他们没有，他们实际上必须付钱给巫医，以获得他的“药”，获得他的超自然力量。疯马无疑拥有它们。他有关于雷暴、被闪电击中的幻象。
There's a very famous vision he has where the wind blows grass into his hair. And then he has this vision when he knows that he has been given the role of fighting for his people. And from that point onwards, he always wears straws of grass in his hair. But he also has this famous one, doesn't he, of a man on a horse rising out of a lake. It's right. Yeah, it does. Who says to him, you must never wear a war bonnet. So he never does. And that's really unusual.
他有一个非常著名的幻象，风把草吹进他的头发里。然后他有了这个幻象，当他知道他被赋予了为他的人民而战的角色时。从那时起，他总是戴着草茎在头发里。但他也有那个著名的，不是吗，一个骑马的人从湖里升起。没错。是的。谁对他说，你永远不能戴战帽。所以他从来不戴。这真的很不寻常。
So basically he rides, I mean, apart from his pants and his moccasins, he rides naked, doesn't he? He does indeed. He's also told he can't be killed by a bullet. You will die by being stabbed, but you cannot be shot. The trouble is, Tom, with all these stories, we've had them obviously very much at third hand by people telling scouts, Indians telling newspaper interviewers in later life kind of what they wanted to hear. So perhaps there's some degree of taking all of them with a pinch of salt. I think that's less true with Crazy Horse. Than with Sitting Bull? I think
所以基本上他骑马时，除了他的裤子和莫卡辛鞋，他基本上是裸体的，不是吗？他确实如此。他还被告知他不能被子弹杀死。你会死于被刺伤，但你不能被枪杀。汤姆，所有这些故事的问题在于，我们显然是从第三手得到的，由那些告诉侦察兵、印第安人在晚年告诉报纸采访者他们想听的内容的人那里得到的。所以也许在某种程度上，所有这些都需要持保留态度。我认为这在疯马身上不太适用。比坐牛（Sitting Bull）更不适用？我想
Sitting Bull definitely plays to the gallery. I think that most of them do. So, you know, the thing about the photograph, Sitting Bull and Red Cloud both allow themselves to be photographed, both kind of looking as American photographers expect a Sue Chieftain to look like. Yeah. But also, you know, Red Cloud kind of pops up wearing top hats and things. Crazy Horse doesn't. No. Because I think one of the reasons why he's such a charismatic figure and why he's maintained his allure into the present day is that he seems to have had a kind of integrity. He seems to have had a kind of instinctive sense that he doesn't want to compromise with
坐牛绝对是在迎合观众。我认为他们大多数人都是这样。所以，你知道，关于照片的事情，坐牛和红云都允许自己被拍照，都看起来像美国摄影师期望苏族酋长看起来的样子。是的。但同时，你知道，红云有点戴着高礼帽之类的出现。疯马没有。不。因为我认为他之所以是一个如此有魅力的人物，以及为什么他能保持他的魅力直到今天，是因为他似乎有一种正直。他似乎有一种本能的感觉，他不想妥协于
his truth. I totally agree, Tom. And so I suspect that the stories that he tells, I mean, true again is the kind of loaded word, but I don't think he's shaping them to the expectations of his white listeners. I mean, I suspect that they are likely to be truer than say sitting bulls. So all the stuff about how he paints kind of white hail spots on his body, doesn't he? And a lightning bolt down his cheek, kind of quite Harry Potter. And he ties brown pebbles behind one ear and all this kind of, he has very kind of distinctive rituals. I suspect that must be true, both because
他的真相。我完全同意，汤姆。所以我怀疑他讲述的故事，我的意思是，真实再次是一个沉重的词，但我不认为他在根据白人听众的期望来塑造它们。我的意思是，我怀疑它们可能比坐牛的更真实。所以所有关于他如何在身上画白冰雹点，不是吗，脸颊上有一道闪电，有点像《哈利·波特》。他在一只耳朵后面系上棕色鹅卵石，所有这些，他有非常独特的仪式。我怀疑那一定是真的，既因为
it would have come from him, but also because so many people would have seen him. It would have been his branding. Well, he has a branding. He has a very strong, as you say, sense of his own. I think integrity is the right word. He's a loner. He doesn't join in with the rituals very much. He doesn't join in with councils. He doesn't even join in with the Sundance, the annual big, big religious ritual. He's a man who walks alone. But on one point, everybody agrees, Crazy Horse is by far the outstanding warrior. He's the bravest. He's the most intrepid. He's also a brilliant tactician. And so when Red Cloud's war starts in the mid-1860s, this is the moment when the Lakota are finally going to stand up to the incursions of all the kind of white settlers, to the US Army and so on. When that fighting breaks out, it's Red Cloud who is the kind of political face of it, but it is Crazy Horse who is going to be the military face, the standard
它会来自他，也因为很多人会看到他。那会是他的品牌。嗯，他有一个品牌。正如你所说，他对自己有一种非常强烈的感觉。我认为正直是正确的词。他是一个孤独者。他不太参加仪式。他不参加议会。他甚至不参加太阳舞，那个年度盛大的宗教仪式。他是一个独行的人。但在一点上，每个人都同意，疯马是迄今为止最杰出的战士。他是最勇敢的。他是最无畏的。他也是一位出色的战术家。所以当红云战争在19世纪60年代中期开始时，这是拉科塔人最终要反抗所有白人定居者、美国军队等的入侵的时刻。当战斗爆发时，红云是政治门面，但疯马将是军事门面，是战场上抵抗的旗手。
bearer of resistance in the field. And I think that, again, this is the parallel with Custer. They've shared a boyhood nickname, Curly, but there are also obvious parallels that Crazy Horse has won fame very young, as Custer has done. Clearly, Crazy Horse has Custer's ability to spot an opportunity, to strike hard, kind of Alexander the Great style. Like Custer, he is completely fearless. But I think there is a difference, and that is the fact that Crazy Horse is never reckless. He always scopes out the strategic context. It was noted of him, and seen as something distinctive, that he would dismount before shooting. He wants to do this because he wants to make certain of his shot. Before going in for the kill, he will pause. He will
我认为，这再次与卡斯特形成了平行。他们分享了一个童年的绰号“卷毛”，但也有明显的相似之处，即疯马很年轻就赢得了名声，正如卡斯特所做的那样。显然，疯马拥有卡斯特那种发现机会、猛烈打击的能力，亚历山大大帝风格。像卡斯特一样，他完全无所畏惧。但我认为有一个区别，那就是疯马从不鲁莽。他总是审视战略背景。人们注意到他，并将其视为独特之处，他会在射击前下马。他想这样做是因为他想确保他的射击。在进行杀戮之前，他会暂停。他会
work out what the best situation is. That, of course, is a contrast with Custer. And it kind of brilliantly sets up the dynamic for the rest of the series, which essentially is the great showdown between Custer and Crazy Horse. Although, Dominic, of course, Crazy Horse is not the only Lakota chieftain. We opened with the other celebrated leader. We did. Sitting Bull. We shamed ourselves, Tom. We talked so long that we're going to have to record an entirely separate episode all about the other great character, and he is an incredible character, and that, of course, is Sitting Bull.
计算出最好的情况是什么。这当然与卡斯特形成了对比。它出色地为本系列的其余部分奠定了动态，这本质上是卡斯特和疯马之间的大对决。虽然，多米尼克，当然，疯马不是唯一的拉科塔酋长。我们以另一位著名的领袖开场。我们确实这样做了。坐牛。我们羞辱了自己，汤姆。我们谈得太久了，以至于我们必须录制一集完全独立的剧集，专门讲述另一个伟大的人物，他是一个不可思议的人物，那当然就是坐牛。
So I think in the next episode, what we'll cover, we'll talk about what happens in Red Clouds War, the very tangled relationship between the Lakota Sioux and the federal government. And we will talk specifically about the life and times of Sitting Bull. And he really is a quite remarkable character. Yeah, he's a brilliant character. I mean, in his way, just as charismatic as Crazy Horse, but in a completely different way. Oh, definitely. And if you like visions and religious rituals, which you do. Oh, so much.
所以我认为在下一集中，我们将涵盖，我们将谈论红云战争中发生了什么，拉科塔苏族和联邦政府之间非常纠缠的关系。我们将专门谈论坐牛的生活和时代。他确实是一个非常了不起的人物。是的，他是一个出色的角色。我的意思是，以他的方式，和疯马一样有魅力，但以一种完全不同的方式。哦，绝对。如果你喜欢幻象和宗教仪式，你喜欢。哦，太喜欢了。
If you like hooks being put into the sinews of the chest, you're going to love what's coming in the next episode. Have we got an episode for you? So if you love hooks that much, you can listen to that episode right now, Tom. You can join our own, is tribe the right word? I don't know.
如果你喜欢钩子被放进胸部的肌腱里，你会喜欢下一集中即将发生的事情。我们为你准备了一集吗？所以如果你那么喜欢钩子，你现在就可以听那一集，汤姆。你可以加入我们自己的，部落是正确的词吗？我不知道。
Our own Sundance. I prefer tribe to chat community, which is the line that we're always being pushed to read by our producers. You can join the Restless History Club and hear that episode right now. If not, you'll have to wait till whenever Theo, in his wisdom, deigns to put it out. And on that bombshell, thank you very much. And we will see you next time for Sitting Bull.
我们自己的太阳舞。我更喜欢部落而不是聊天社区，这是我们的制片人总是强迫我们读的台词。你可以加入《其余皆历史》俱乐部，现在就听那一集。如果没有，你将不得不等到西奥以他的智慧决定发布它的那天。在那颗重磅炸弹上，非常感谢。我们下次再见，讲述坐牛。
Bye-bye. pull back the curtain on entertainment, and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。揭开娱乐业的幕布，我们告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。